[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
careless and I know I say that a lot
right I know I say there's another
exciting episode of kill West but not
this this this time right here this time
right here this is a truly exciting
episode of Kos so I did the video
yesterday did the unboxing yesterday I
uploaded everything yesterday and I was
a little Thai and I was a lot of sorts
and come to find out the video that I
did got corrupted 2nd video ok videos
give now world got to see this guy
this is sideshows maquette juggernaut
the unstoppable juggernaut I never
thought that I would get a juggernaut
stature I mean I was looking I saw a
bowling statue so custom statues and
then lo and behold sideshow puts up for
pre-order the juggernaut and I quickly
jumped on it got the exclusive Edition
well Inoue makes it exclusive check it
out
since Kitty Pryde fall y'all who know
the x-men this is Kitty Pryde
all right so they got her phasing in
looking with the portrait Portuguese
crazy
they got her phasing through the floor
well she comes separate she can you can
actually put her on her own little spin
right here you see but um you can also
place on the base just like in the movie
where she phases through the floor and
she touches the juggernaut leg and pulls
them through the floor Katie pride is a
mutant that is with the x-men right and
how powers is she's able to phase
through solid objects and whatever she
touches she can bring it into the solid
object now if she releases him that
those both solid objects become infused
with each other she can definitely do
some bad stuff
she's a very underrated unit and a lot
of you guys probably think the
juggernaut is a mutant well he isn't the
jugular the juggernaut first appeared in
x-men 111 and 112 and he is the
stepbrother of Charles Xavier who is
immune now Cain Marko was that's the
juggernauts real name he was on
expedition in some mountains and he
found a ruby a giant Ruby and not
knowing to him when he grabbed the Ruby
sit erect an ancient deity who chooses
his champions and infuses his powers his
power of chaos destruction
to his champions and from that moment on
Cain Marko was the champion of CID Iraq
and he came unstoppable juggernaut the
unstoppable juggernaut uh he wasn't he
hasn't been portrayed well in the movies
let's keep it real
one of the first x-men movies he was
some skinny guy in in a muscle suit and
nice little catchphrase you know I'm
sorry I just wasn't about it I was happy
that they did it I was happy that they
tried to represent the character but no
that wasn't my cup of tea now shout out
to Ryan Reynolds who has a comic book
accurate Deadpool and decided to let's
get the juggernaut in the movie now
understandably his armor the helmet and
stuff all the stuff would be hard so
what they tried to do was get it to a
point where it's somewhat comic-book
accurate but they got his society's down
pat they got the juggernaut size down
pack so shout out to Ryan Reynolds in
Deadpool 2 then did that movie and got
us to juggernaut and I liked the
depiction of the character there it was
it was pretty good it wasn't so much but
he did have his fight with Colossus and
that is what this is all about the big
boys brawling so I always love when John
Romita Jr did Colossus vs the juggernaut
oh he drew the juggernaut in general and
um
I'm with this you know um I'm with John
Romita Jr artwork and I thought he had
the best of pictures you know sometimes
when he have him fighting spider-man or
Wolverine great stuff even in the
cartoon
yeah the cartoon with the juggernaut
versus Colossus and I have a colossus
coming from sideshow so you guys are
definitely gonna see that those do big
boys get together do you see how big he
is literally this is the same size as my
fence almost look at that huge huge
statues huge my hand is big okay
all right get the scale of this look at
that
[Music]
big statue huge highly detailed
statue 100% fantastic the level of
detail in the statue is nuts now I have
another statue would the jug amount
that's him versus Wolverine but I wanted
a standalone one and he's pretty much
standalone to be honest with you all I
have to do is take 80 pride all for this
but Wow
the face even in the helmet there is a
separate head
there's not one mold they pulled out all
the stops from the rail wiring to the
metal to the base I'm bussing through
the danger room knocking down the door
with his fists to the charge this on his
legs to the textures of the boots to the
muscle is the muscle mass to the veins
you can see in his arms you know you can
actually see the veins within his skin
the texture of the teeth the fingernails
the knuckles the prints everything
sideshow spared no expense here okay
statue came in and uh what is it uh
$13.99 fourteen hundred and then
shipping I got number one twenty out of
400 in sane I'm so happy that I was able
to get it this is truly a testament of
sideshows artwork design care of a
character and commitment to bringing you
the best
statues that they can actually bring it
was one from XM that I was looking at
because XM was doing a sideshow
juggernaut as well I didn't go with the
XM one because of the Marvel characters
and then their licensing stuff that they
have going on with them I truly believe
that I got a fantastic statue and I'm
thoroughly pleased huge oh it comes in
two shipper boxes now a lot of people
upset because it doesn't come with an
art box usually you get the shipper box
and the art box well they didn't do art
box but what they did do was they gave
you an art print right and on the back
of the art print they gave you a
tutorial on how to put together your
statue with the base the five pieces
that goes for the base and the more than
five pieces that actually go to the
juggernaut I thought this was fantastic
and if you need assistance this is how
heavy and how intricate this statue is
you need in some assembly instructions
they have phone numbers for you to call
just in case you get lost putting them
together because it is a daunting task I
am not gonna lie
now I've been juggling I fan almost
forever
and to get the statue in my house he's
gonna have his own place gonna have his
own little section it's gonna be
represented well also I used to play him
in our case I got an arcade machine and
I play this character I love the
character and I got the character in the
household now so I'm going to pick them
in the best situation I possibly can so
this is the part of the video when I
would like for you guys to like follow
and subscribe go to Lords of gaming
dotnet where you can see more of Kos and
you know get this statue see more of the
statute read about the dimensions you
can check out more information on the
juggernaut there also you can see a law
Cognito with the last word with Yvonne
tests and you can get Lord addicts
hardcore reviews the website is great we
have a lot of writers there where I have
tons of opinion pieces a lot of reviews
you can also catch catch Lords of I'm so
good right now you can actually catch
our podcast there iron Lords listen we
have a ton of fun I would like for you
to stick around see this video see the
pitches see this statue in all his glory
as I go up close and super detailed with
this wonderful statue again thank you
guys for tuning in and I am super
pleased to bring you size shows maquette
unstoppable juggernaut see you next week
well I'll bring you that guy over there
told you if he showed up nothing can
stop the juggernaut
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]